>> Greg: IT'S DAY FIVE OF
THE KANYE APOCALYPSE.
AS PREDICTED IF YOU STEP OUT
OF THE BOX, THE OTHERS STILL
IN JAIL WILL TURN ON YOU.
>> SO NOW DONALD TRUMP HAS
TWO BLACK FRIENDS.
THEY HAVE GOT.
[LAUGHTER]
I HOPE BEN CARSON DOESN'T
GET JEALOUS.
>> I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED HERE.
I THINK KANYE WEST JUST
REALIZED HE IS TOO RICH TO
NOT BE REPUBLICAN.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT IS.
>> WE HAVE THE RIGHT TO
INDEPENDENT THOUGHT AND I
INDEPENDENTLY THINK THAT
KANYE HAS LOST HIS MIND
GUILT GUT WHAT AN
OVERREACTION YOU WOULD THINK
HE ADVOCATED FOR CHILD
MARRIAGE.
IT'S JUST LIKE HIGH SCHOOL.
THE PERSON WHO WON'T ACT
LIKE EVERYONE ELSE GETS THE
SHAFT.
ISN'T IT ODD THAT HOLLYWOOD
LECTURES US ON BULLYING AND
THE DIVERSIFIED BUT WHEN IT
COMES RIGHT DOWN TO IT THEY
ARE GROUP THINK ENFORCERS
INTOLERANT OF INDIVIDUALITY.
WHY IS THAT?
THE CURSE AGAIN OF IDENTITY
POLITICS WHICH PUTS THE
GROUP BEFORE THE PERSON.
ALSO BEHIND THE MOCKERY IS A
FEAR THAT THEIR TARGET MIGHT
BE ON TO SOMETHING MOCKERS
ARE BEING LEFT HIMSD.
SOMEONE DARES TO BE
DIFFERENT WITH A WAY THAT
COMES WITH A COST YOU EITHER
EEVALUATE YOUR OWN SOURCES
OR SEEK TO SEE YOU LENS HIM
OR HER.
WHICH LEADS ME TO ANOTHER
CRITICISM THOSE ON THE RIGHT
LAUDING KANYE WOULD RIP HIM
APART IF HIS COMMENTS WERE
LEFT WING.
WHAT IF IT WAS ABOUT NEEDING
MORE GUN CONTROL.
IT'S ACTUALLY A FAIR POINT
EXCEPT IT MISSES THE BIG
PICTURE.
WHAT KANYE IS DOING, UNLIKE
THAT POSITION, ISN'T A
REFLECTION OF THE SAME
CONVENTIONAL ASSUMPTIONS
THAT GETS GREAT PRESS.
YOU KNOW, THIS IS A DARING
MOVE BECAUSE IT GOES AGAINST
THAT VERY TIDE.
THUS, IT'S ONE THAT COSTS
YOU CAPITAL, SUPPORT FROM
YOUR ENTERTAINMENT PALS AND
EVEN RECORD SALES.
HE WILL DIDN'T JOIN A
PARADE.
HE LEFT A PRISON AND HE IS
PAYING FOR IT.
BUT MAYBE THAT'S WHY CAN YEA
DID IT, HE REALIZED THAT HE
COULD ABSORB THE SLINGS AND
ARROWS THAT OTHERS COULDN'T.
WHO DOES THAT REMIND YOU OF?
AND NOT DONALD TRUMP.
>> Jesse: ME?
[LAUGHTER]
>> Kimberly: KIM OH MY GOD.
JESUS JESUS RHYMES IS ESUS.
>> Dana: YOU ARE COMPARING.
>> Greg: HE SUFFERED THE
SLINGS -- IS HE RISKING
HIMSELF FOR THE GOOD OF
OTHERS.
>> Dana: I WAS WITH YOU ALL
THE WAY UNTIL JESUS.
>> Greg: PEOPLE TALK ABOUT
PEOPLE CHRISTLIKE.
IS HE WILLING TO SACRIFICE A
LOT OF HIMSELF FOR OTHERS.
I WELCOME THE LAUGHTER
BECAUSE I'M ALSO SACRIFICING
MYSELF.
>> Dana: YOU DON'T BELIEVE
IN JESUS.
>> Jesse: HE BELIEVES IN
ESUS.
>> Juan: THIS IS TOO MUCH.
>> Greg: DID I THAT FOR YOU,
JUAN.
DID I THAT FOR YOU.
>> Kimberly: YOU PUT HIM
OVER THE EDGE.
WELL DONE.
>> Greg: LET'S GO TO THIS.
DONALD TRUMP TALKING ABOUT
KANYE.
>> I GET ALONG WITH KANYE.
I GET ALONG WITH AT LOVE
PEOPLE FRANKLY.
BUT KANYE LOOKS AND HE
CEASES BLACK UNEMPLOYMENT AT
THE LOWEST IT'S BEEN IN THE
HISTORY OF OUR COUNTRY,
OKAY?
HE SEES THAT STUFF AND HE IS
SMART AND HE SAYS, YOU KNOW
WHAT?
TRUMP IS DOING A MUCH BETTER
JOB THAN THE DEMOCRATS DID.
WHEN I SEE A KANYE STICKING
TO HIS GUNS, OR WHEN I SEE
OTHERS AND THERE ARE PLENTY
OF OTHERS, STICKING TO THEIR
GUNS, AND COMING OUT AND
SAYING IT --
>> Greg: DANA?
>> Dana: ONE OF THE THINGS I
LEARNED TODAY IS YOUR POINT
ABOUT GETTING KICKED OUT OF
YOUR TRIBE IS THAT DO YOU
KNOW THAT HE WAS ACTUALLY --
THEY SAID THAT KANYE WAS
PART OF THE ALT RIGHT.
>> Greg: I KNOW.
>> Dana: THIS IS
PREPOSTEROUS THAT HE IS PART
OF THE ALT RIGHT.
AND YOU KNOW HOW I FEEL
ABOUT HIM IN TERMS OF THE
PAST.
I'M WILLING TO LET IT GO.
CONSERVATIVES HAVE BEEN
SAYING SIMILAR THINGS FOR